jean-françois de lauzun ingénieur
polytechnicien n'avait jamais eu maille
à partir avec la police
mais le 19 août 2008 alors qu'il rentre
chez lui après son travail il prend une
petite libertés avec le code de la route
le petit bonhomme au thon rouge et j'ai
traversé puisqu'il n'y avait strictement
aucun danger
il y avait une voiture de police qui
étaient garés et qui attendait au feu
rouge la policière ou verse à la fenêtre
et s'est adressé à moi vous l'a alors le
petit bonhomme était rouge
alors moi je les écoutais et j'ai
continué mon chemin
la fonctionnaire de police poursuit
jean-françois de lauzun à pied elle
appelle ses collègues en renfort pour un
contrôle d'identité
plusieurs badauds s'arrêtent et le ton
monte j'ai pris les gens à témoin la
foule et j'ai dit mon rendez compte on
fait un contrôle d'identité pour avoir
traversé la rue ready for bernard copin
artisan peintre sort à ce moment là d'un
chantier tout proche
il ya un des trois policiers qu'à une
matraque à la main et qui est très
menaçant donc mon sens a fait un petit
tour en disant mais qu'est ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire selon la
fonctionnaire de police les deux hommes
l'ont injurié ce qu'il nie j'ai été
contrôlé et en retraversant la rue pour
la ma voiture
alma interpellé à eau à haute voix en
disant vous vous aurez de mes nouvelles
puis c'est tout mais moi j'ai fait un
geste comme ça partout les pôles des
nouvelles vous savez vous
chacun rentre chez soi mais le soir venu
deux policiers se présentent à la
résidence de jean-françois de lauzun
pour lui remettre une convocation à se
rendre au commissariat
sa femme les laisse entrer dans le
bâtiment il est 22h30
je leur dis mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ces méthodes totalitaires
le premier policier se précipite sur moi
il me met les menottes sur la main
droite
le deuxième en chaîne sur la main gauche
et que je me suis retrouvé menotté et ma
femme m'a dit mais pourquoi vous
l'arrêter et le premier a dit
totalitaire c'est une insulte
jean-françois de lauzun est emmenée en
pyjama et robe de chambre au
commissariat de versailles pour la
première fois de sa vie il découvre la
garde à vue et ses petites humiliations
ça pue élus rinne j'ai compris pourquoi
et qui les interdisent aux gens d'aller
aux toilettes
donc voilà alors j'insiste il dit je
suis seul donc je ne peux pas vous
accompagner pour l'autre lettre pan et
finalement j'ai été obligé de me
soulager dans la dans la cellule
les policiers cherchent également à
convoquer bernard copin mais l'artisan
peintre n'est pas à son domicile
une voisine les oriente vers la
pharmacie où travaille sa compagne
patricia l'amant qui prévient son
concubin
très vite la situation bascule un
policier met la main sur l'épaule de
bernard copin pour l'emmener selon les
fonctionnaires il les aurait insulté et
se serait violemment débattu l'artisan
est alors plaqué au sol sans ménagement
bilan dix jours d'arrêt de travail
bernard copin et menottés et emmenés au
commissariat
tout comme sa compagne qui n'a pas
participé à l'altercation
elle pense simplement être entendue
policiers qui est derrière moi me pousse
assez violemment pour que je rentre et
je me retrouve assise sur le banc et là
on me met les menottes et c'est là qu'il
ya des policiers commencent à me tutoyer
money sera toi c'est cette ta garde à
vue cocotte commence maintenant pour 24
heures reconductible alors là je les
bras m'en tombent
et je leur demande pour quelle raison et
ils me disent pour violences aggravées
contre policiers capteurs sont assignés
il me dit de toute manière je suis
assermentés c'est ta parole contre la
mienne cocotte n'a pas l'air bien de 30
compte de ce qui va t'arriver fille de
gardiens de la paix patricia l'amant
connaît un peu les procédures
judiciaires
elle est d'autant plus choqué par la
fouille à nu normalement exceptionnel
qu'une policière va lui faire subir les
commentaires c'est écarte les jambes
de quoi vous vous étiez quelque chose
à des endroits précis et donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez humiliant patricia
l'amant passera tout de même 24 heures
en garde à vue et pourtant la justice ne
trouvera rien à lui reprocher alors que
dit la loi
selon le code de procédure pénale
n'importe quelle infraction peut vous
conduire en garde à vue même la plus
minime vol à l'étalagé infractions
routières ou encore outrage à agent à
partir de l'âge de 13 ans
tout le monde peut se retrouver en garde
à vue s'il y a des raisons plausibles de
soupçonner que la personne a commis ou
tenté de commettre une infraction
le placement en garde à vue est
déclenché pour les nécessités de
l'enquète à la libre appréciation du
gendarme du policier ou du douanier ou
que vous êtes en gare de venir elle peut
durer quatre heures normalement la
détention doit durer moins de 24 heures
mais elle peut être prolongée jusqu'à
quatre jours pour les cas les plus
graves
voilà pour le cadre légal
mais ce qui choque le plus souvent ce
sont les conditions concrètes de la
garde à vue un sujet très sensible
après huit semaines d'âpres négociations
le ministère de l'intérieur nous a
autorisés à filmer quelques heures dans
un hôtel de police choisi par ses soins
à argenteuil en région parisienne c'est
un commissariat modèle inauguré il ya
tout juste un an
un homme d'une trentaine d'années vient
d'être interpellé
il est soupçonné de vol avec violence
pour un téléphone portable
l'homme est menotté au banc ce n'est pas
obligatoire mais par sécurité
c'est l'option choisie par les policiers
la plupart du temps
on va vous emmener voir l'officier
d'accord pour notre tournage c'est un
haut gradé du commissariat le commandant
couderc qui va diriger la garde à vue
qu'on soit là bas vous savez pourquoi
vous êtes là monsieur dont vous avez été
reconnu par une victime sur une affaire
de vol devrions ses côtés monsieur on a
besoin de faire une petite enquête pour
ça on a besoin de vous garder un petit
rond soldats quand je vois vous placé en
garde à vue pour ça à ce moment précis
de la procédure
l'officier doit lui dire ses droits si
la loi est ce que vous voulez je
prévienne quelqu'un vous avez la famille
à prévenir vous avez non non est ce que
voulait voir un médecin si vous êtes
malade non est ce que vous voulez voir
un avocat ça c'était pas mal si on voit
ça il vous
vous expliquerez un petit peu ce qui se
vouent comprenait pas d'accord le
policier n'est pas seul aux commandes
il doit rendre compte à un magistrat le
procureur de la république
il appelle au téléphone vous téléphonent
pour réaliser des placements en garde à
vue d'une personne alors depuis 16h15
mais au quotidien bien souvent cela se
résume à un simple fax le jeune homme
est maintenant on est on sait lully
petit rester 24 heures reconductible
avec l'accord du procureur l'homme et
étrangers manifestement il n'a pas
compris qu'il n'était plus libre de ses
mouvements
si vite fait
le jeune homme pénètre dans la zone
d'enfermement c'est souvent le moment le
plus difficile à vivre
il faut enlever sa ceinture et ses
bijoux tout objet susceptible de
présenter un danger pour soi ou pour les
autres il y a également la fameuse
fouilles
mais cette fois ci elle ne sera pas
effectuée à nu c'est bon ça dépend des
individus ça dépend de la situation ça
dépend de la façon dont on perçoit cet
individu
ce sont des paramètres qui t'a fait
jurer qu'il est pour les femmes
une disposition est particulièrement
désagréable on enlève au soutien gorge
parce que même si une ceinture et un
lacet de chaussure on peut se trouver
les chaussures restent à l'extérieur car
les détenus ont tendance à s'en servir
pour tambouriner aux portes de toilettes
séparées par un mur points d'eau cellule
individuelle et surveillance vidéo
dernier cri
ce commissariat est ce qui se fait de
mieux
il ya même une douche commune à tous les
détenus
l'avocat de permanence christian gallon
se présente à l'entrée pour monsieur
il a trente minutes pour discuter avec
le gardé à vue est ce qu a eu des
problèmes particuliers ce que je veux a
noté des choses je note tout ce que vous
voulez et ça sera dans le dossier du
tribunal
oui je le dis je me suis surpassé vous
risquez quand même de passer la nuit
dans les geôles regard de l'assistance
de l'avocat est toute relative car le
lendemain c'est sans lui que le détenu
sera interrogé m galons n'a de toute
façon pas accès au dossier
c'est une intervention
j'avais presque inutile en tout cas on
n'exerce pas à ce stade un homme drôle
données font seuls ça c'est clair
il est 19h30 c'est l'heure du dîner
au menu ce soir du riz à la provençale
réchauffer au micro ondes un repas
gratuit
pourquoi
mais ce commissariat modèle ne reflètent
pas toute la réalité à paris voici
l'homme qui connaît le mieux l'état réel
des locaux de garde à vue jean marie
delarue un haut fonctionnaire de 65 ans
dirige un organisme officiel chargé de
contrôler les lieux de privation de
liberté
son équipe a visité près de 150 cellules
depuis deux ans son constat est sévère
pouf voilà venez voir c'est un une vue
en plongée n'est ce pas d'une toile est
installé dans une cellule de garde à vue
qui est une toilette dit à la turque
elle n'a pas été nettoyé je n'insiste
pas sur les saletés sur le mur vous avez
ici une espèce de couchettes de bois
alors il ya beaucoup de commissariats
dans lequel ça n'existe pas ceux ci
alors ça ne rend pas les choses un peu
plus confortable
ça rend les choses simplement un peu
moins froides on donne quelquefois des
couvertures si on vous en donne alors
vaste problème de savoir si la
couverture a été nettoyé donc il ya des
personnes qui refusent la couverture
parce que elle est un mets table ne
serait ce que pour la vue l'odeur si je
puis dire et donc que les gens préfèrent
le froid plus tôt que la couverture
c'est tout le temps comme ça locaux
garde à vue ah non il y en a des pires y
en a des pistes des lieux de détention
vétuste que l'on retrouverait dans trois
quarts des commissariats de france
voici donc le contexte dans lequel se
déroule près de 900000 garde à vue
chaque année
comment at on atteint un tel chiffre
d'abord parce que la loi est plus sévère
depuis quelques années pour les
infractions routières notamment qui sont
à l'origine d'un tiers des gardes à vue
ensuite parce que leur nombre est devenu
l'un des critères de performance des
commissariats
c'est un des critères de l'activité de
la police
nous avons mis en garde à vue douze
mille six cent treize personnes
nous avons une augmentation des gardes à
vue délits de droit commun de 0 82% et
plus ces chiffres augmentent
mieux les policiers sont notés mais côté
citoyen si l'on estime que la garde à
vue est abusive
y at-il une possibilité de contester
gare montparnasse à paris
ce matin nous avons rendez vous avec un
couple de rambouillet à qui il est
arrivé une histoire incroyable il ya un
an au cours d'un dîner de famille leurs
deux enfants de 9 et 12 ans vont jouer
dans la rue mais il est deux heures du
matin une patrouille de police passe et
embarque des enfants au poste au
commissariat les parents sont très
énervés
selon les policiers il les aurait
insulté du coup deux semaines plus tard
ils sont convoqués pour outrage à agent
à leur grande surprise ils sont placés
en garde à vue ce qu'aujourd'hui encore
ils n'ont pas compris
les policiers qui nous ont traités comme
des bandits comme des voyous soit
un petit peu inquiété de la manière dont
ils se sont comportés et qu'ils aient
des comptes à rendre sur leur façon de
faire et leur façon de traiter les gens
devant la justice leur plainte n'aurait
aucune chance d'aboutir car la loi a été
respectée
leur seul recours se trouve ici à la
cnds la commission de déontologie de la
sécurité
un organisme chargé de pointe et les
abus de la police aujourd'hui c'est un
ancien directeur de prison et un avocat
qui les reçoivent chacun et entendus
séparément avant des entretiens avec
avec l'officier de police
elle me toise elle me elle me demande
sèchement le strict minimum
mes papiers
nom ma date de naissance je travaille
elle est sèche elle est méchante vous
mentez m'a démoli bien démoli puis comme
ça après ça m'a interrogé quoi
l'interroger quelqu'un de démo ni vous
avez des observations sur le déroulement
de cette mesure qu'ils se disent sûrs
pas qu'on aime qu'on m'ait demandé de me
des amis m'ont suivi réglementaire à
widnes on met d'accord mais pourquoi
j'étais hors garde à vue moi est ce
qu'il y avait besoin que je sois placé
en garde à vue
c'est au tour du mari d'être auditionné
ces duffy fin c'est un viol quoi c'est
un violent autant et violée quand vous
avez fait quelque chose de grave je dis
pas le contraire mais là on peut pas
comprendre on peut pas ne pas comprendre
fin de l'audition
elle aura duré une heure et demie pour
la première fois le couple a pu exprimer
officiellement sa souffrance
ce sera ensuite au tour des policiers
d'être entendu c'est bien parce que déjà
on s'occupe de nous mais bon qu'est ce
qui va leur arriver
j'espère que ça va les empêcher un petit
peu de dormir d'être convoqué ici
les époux repartent dans leur village de
la région parisienne
une semaine plus tard les policiers sont
attendus pour être auditionné mais le
jour venu personnes apparemment les
fonctionnaires ont eu vente la présence
de la caméra
pourtant la commission n'a pas grand
pouvoir elle se limite à envoyer des
avis au ministère de l'intérieur
des habits qui selon elle n'ont jamais
été suivies de sanctions disciplinaires